[موسيقى]
من 50 سنه الشيخ محمد الغزالي رحمه الله
نبه في كثير من كتبه على قضيه مهمه جدا في
السنه وهي قضيه اسباب ورود الحديث في علوم
القران هناك اسباب النزول في السنه هناك
اسباب ورود الحديث في مؤلفات قليله لان
هناك الكثير من الاحاديث النبويه قيلت في
مناسبات معينه يعني النبي عليه الصلاه
والسلام لما قال امرت ان اقاتل الناس لا
يمكن ان يحمل كلمه الناس على عمومها لان
عندنا ايات قرانيه وقاتل في سبيل الله
الذين يقاتلونكم ولا تعتدوا انما
المناسبات تقول بان امرت ان يقاتل الناس
المشركين الذين كانوا يرفعون عليه السلام
[موسيقى]
لابد ان تنقح في التراث وان تنقي وانا
ضربتني
سيدنا ادم كان في الجنه وبعدين نام وبعدين
ام لا قاعده جنبه انت مين انا خرجت من
ضلعك الايسر لما
يتقبل هذا ربما الطبري معذور لانه جماع